[Musique]
lundi soir m6 diffusait un nouvel
épisode de son émission de dating
devenue culte
et si on se rencontrait à c'est du
fantasme à la réalité réserve toujours
des surprises des bonnes comme des
mauvaises un concept plutôt simple deux
candidats qui se parlent virtuellement
depuis longtemps qu'ils se rencontrent
sous les yeux des caméras elle encore
plus belle en vrai qu'en photo c'est
vraiment la personne que j'imaginais
tout de même mieux
lundi soir les téléspectateurs ont fait
la découverte de najet une candidate en
fauteuil roulant qui après cinq mois des
changes à travers un écran a pris son
courage à deux mains pour rencontrer
sofiane c'est quelqu'un avec qui je me
sens bien je parle
les joyeux et plein de vielles janvier
une rencontre très émouvante qui a
beaucoup touché les téléspectateurs
notamment face à la tendresse et la
bienveillance de sofiane malheureusement
l'alchimie entre les deux ne paiera pas
ils décideront de rester amis
actuellement je te considère comme ma
meilleure amie
ce soir najet et sofiane sont avec nous
pour nous raconter cette formidable
expérience
la games super bien on la connaît bien
les gens l'adorent
bon c'était une belle aventure oui
j'aimerais même sapa match et je
regrette pas au gouvernement parce que
contrairement à ce que ton pain c'était
assure jouer ni quoi que ce soit enfin
tout cas pour ma part c'était vraiment
tout était sincère je suis à l'écran
comme je suis dans la vie donc voilà je
ne regrette pas après c'est vrai que ça
a été comme ça sofiane voir ça va bien
bienvenue la socgen quand même bon bah
c'est alors quand vous êtes rencontrés
est-ce que vous connaissiez najet
complètement out téléphone non une année
complète ça vous fait vous saviez
qu'elle avait un handicap ou pas ouais
ça serait quand même tous avaient tous
tout était clair d'accord alors
visiblement des jets à l'été elle était
bien sûr le dossier étant même c'est
vrai franchement vous étiez un peu comme
un proche et vous moi moi c'est ça a
toujours été mon ami à vous ses friends
of rain dance ainsi de friends and mais
c'était mon ami d'accord mais vous
samedi qu'ils avaient aimé parce que ça
s'appelle et si on se rencontre et
bonbons faire un scrabble a priori non
après il m'a proposé de venir la faire
avec m je suis allé parce que en fait
vous c'était en fait de l'amitié il
savait savais que j'allais vous savez
quelle est l an passé un peu pour vous
tu peux me sens vraiment
c'était pas mon truc c'était pas
flagrant elle met bien ça se voyait à
m'envoyer cette année mais quand on voit
la séquence sur m6 et ils ont quand même
fait du rappel suspect avant ils ont
fait monter la mayonnaise
et puis pouf il manqué de sel tout là
ménez est tombé parce que nous on était
déçu quand même que vous soyez pas
ensemble bah oui ouais bah dites c'est
ce que les jours dit il était quant à
lui fait le casting je crois tu avais
dit que justement c'était je crois que
c'était pas de l'amour c'est vraiment
moi j'étais au montage de l'émission il
on peut tourner les choses en disant
voilà qui avait entre guillemets pour
tous est une possibilité c'est ça non
c'est ça oui c'est quand je dis que
c'était amical d'accord alors qu'un
petit montage que vous ne dites qu'est
ce qui a fait que vous êtes sur les
réseaux pour pour chercher l'amour
alors on va pas se mentir c'était pour
ça quand même bauer parce que ça parce
que dans la vie de tous les jours ça ça
n'arrivait pas du tout c'est pas assez
que pas loin de là mais en fait j'en ai
marre que les gens s intéressent à moi
que par rapport à mon physique ou où on
va dire maintenant c'est que par profit
ou après c'est vrai que le handicap qui
fait peur et je parle pas spécialement
de l'émission en général les inconnus
fait peur aux gens parce que souvent on
associe le handicap indépendant je peux
à des choses comme ça et moi c'est un
peu les codes que j'ai envie de casser
de montrer que maintenant c'est pas
parce que tu as un mika fait que tu aies
dépendants ou que on va dire t'as pas le
droit de ne pas avoir quelqu'un de
valide ou quoi que ce soit moi ça va pas
empêcher bon j'ai accumulé les planches
pourries mais ça ça rien à voir
la pensée pour moi je normalement j'en
ai rencontré beaucoup mais alors qu'est
ce qui pourrait vous avez vous accepté
de sa reddition pour se passer des
messages pour ce handicap
pourquoi j'ai accepté de faire
l'émission vous me connaissez un peu
j'ai accepté parce que moi pour moi déjà
c'était un challenge parce que il faut
avoir en avoir dans le pantalon pour
faire ce que j'ai fait parce que c'est
pas évident moi je suis pas quelqu'un
l'expressif et encore moins me dévoiler
comme ça parce que pour moi c'était
vraiment comme si je me mettais nu et
après j'ai accepté de faire cette
émission parce que ben pour comme je
fais dans le mannequinat ou dans le
métier de l'ambiance c'est à dire
montrer aux gens que tout est possible
car rien d'impossible et et j'ai reçu
pas mal de messages en me disant bas en
moyenne l'émission hier avec soutiennent
ou encore cette semaine mais grâce à ça
j'ai j'ai encore de l'espoir et des fois
on les choses et c'est pour ça que j'ai
fait ça l'émission vous avez très bien
que je dépasse évidemment de tout ce
genre de programme et tout s'est pas
totalement mon mac âme mais j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration et de tendresse
pour najet qui avait fait d'ailleurs le
duo dé tout à fait ici rien je me
souviens très bien et je pense que najet
l'a fait effectivement avec avec
beaucoup de sincérité à participer à ce
programme a permis de casser certains
codes
j'ai peut-être un tout petit peu plus de
réticences même si tu es beau comme un
coeur mon petit sofiane j'ai un peu plus
de réticences parce que j'ai
l'impression que la prochaine étape ce
sera la téléréalité est ce que j'ai fait
non ce que vous dites mon physique au
stabilo plaqué par rapport à ton quasi
non en soi pour cent par rapport à la
peut-être par rapport à la chaîne non
non plus et non parce que c'est avec moi
en contact et de le faire moi
personnellement je n'avais pas
m'inscrire dans un programme télé comme
celui ci mais oui mais tu as participé
je me permettais tutoyer oui au casting
à participer à un casting donc en
arrivant au casting tu aurais pu dire
clairement c'est mon ami j'ai peut-être
pas je ne veux pas aller plus loin
pression mais si j'ai fait cet effet là
d'un grand pas pour le jeu fait vous
expliquez vous les fait pour toi ma tête
me contacter pour faire ce oui si je te
revois dans les anges on est d'accord
que j'affiche mes dans l'aisance et
pillé tu peux m'en fiche est inquiète ok
vous laissez pas faire
genre c'est pas moi c'était pas un
programme que moi j'allais faire de moi
même de mon plein gré après plus tard
dans ma vie on allait me contacter pour
autre chose au plus tard oui ça me fait
pied à l'étrier quoi j'étais animé moi
tout ce que j'ai pour la navette